Boa noite a todos é um prazer novamente
estar com vocês em uma Live para tirar
dúvidas e discutirmos alguns
assuntos vamos discutir aqui uns temas
muito interessantes depois passar para
as perguntas de vocês boa noite
Eliseu conforme vocês forem entrando por
favor se identifiquem para eu poder dar
o Alô dar o Boa
noite bem vamos falar hoje sobre um
assunto muito sério que afeta
diretamente a nossa saúde a contaminação
da água por um dos elementos um dos
milhares de elementos mas esse aqui tem
um destaque especial é o tricloroetileno
também conhecido pela sigla
TCE é um solvente industrial e tem sido
amplamente utilizado em processos e
produtos que usamos no dia a dia mas os
impactos negativos da substância TCE
tricloroetileno
são devastadores Então vamos entender
melhor essa história e descobrir como é
que nós podemos nos proteger ele é
utilizado como solvente industrial para
diversas aplicações desde tirar desde
tirar a cafeína no café
descafeinação até limpeza seco Então
pessoal não tomem café descafeinado tá
não é uma
boa infelizmente quando a substância TC
infiltra-se no solo e nas águas
subterrâneas os resultados são
desastrosos estudos recentes têm
demonstrado que a contaminação da água
numa região Estados Unidos chama-se Camp
Legion é uma base militar lá nos Estados
Unidos essa contaminação da água levou
um aumento significativo de casos de
Parkinson e
câncer segundo a agência substâncias
tóxicas e registro de doenças é um órgão
Americano O TC está presente de 9 a 34%
da água potável nos Estados Unidos no
Brasil não tem essa
informação a exposição repetida à
substância está ligada a vários efeitos
ruins no fígado nos íes no sistema de
defesa sistema imune endócrino além de
impactos no desenvolvimento humano Boa
Noite
Marta conforme vocês vem forem entrando
avisem para eu dar uma fou para vocês
então nós sabemos que a poluição da água
hoje é um problema muito sério é um
problema de saúde pública é uma ameaça
iminente à nossas vidas e quando se fala
muito e na minha opinião exageradamente
sobre mudanças climáticas pouco se
discute sobre escassez e contaminação da
água
em em uma única semana de setembro de
2022 várias cidades Americanas
enfrentaram crise de contaminação de
água desde bactérias como eseri Coli na
região de Baltimore até níveis tóxicos
de Arsênio no estado de Nova
York infelizmente anos de poluição
Industrial mal
gerenciamento carregaram a água com
substâncias nocivas como artênio que tá
no arroz também nitratos medicamentos
farmacêuticos pesticidas hormônios né de
antic proficionais e microplástico nós
falamos na semana passada além disso
flur esse
alógeno que é muito utilizado né para
limpeza dentária e também para pasta de
dente etc que funciona também como
disruptor endócrino atrapalha nosso
sistema endócrino sistema
hormonal ele é adicionado
intencionalmente no abastecimento de
água com a justificativa de tá
melhorando a saúde bucal saúde dentária
mas ele já foi associado a alguns
estudos a pior de função
cognitiva então a produção comercial do
tricloro etileno TC começou na Alemanha
em 1925 e nos Estados Unidos na mesma
época ele foi inicialmente utilizado
como anestésico foi rapidamente
substituído por outras substâncias
devido aos efeitos tóxicos no entanto
ele continua a ser utilizado como
desengraxante Industrial o que permitiu
sua Ampla disseminação no abastecimento
de água então O TC foi detectado em
771 locais nos Estados Unidos
representando uma ameaça tanto paraa
qualidade de água quanto do ar em alguns
lugares a exposição ao TC ocorreu até
mesmo durante o banho destacando a
periculosidade dessa substância em
diversas formas de contato falando Mais
especificamente desse caso da base
militar Camp leene que eu não sei como é
que pronuncia Talvez seja leun eh de
francês né é uma base do corpo de
fuzileiros navais nos Estados Unidos foi
um dos casos mais repercutidos de
contaminação com o pce entre 1953 e 85 a
água dessa base estav contaminada
expomos militares trabalhadores a
diversos riscos da Saúde então estudos
mostraram uma maior incidência de
doenças neurodegenerativas como paxon
entre os veteranos que serviram na base
durante esse período em 2012 foi criado
um fundo de 2 Bilhões de Dólares para
compensar as vítimas da
contaminação os veteranos e suas
famílias que estiveram na base por pelo
menos 30 dias entre 57 e 87 tem direito
a benefício de saúde para tratar as 15
condições médicas específicas incluindo
paron então em relação a essa base
militar a primeira medida para resolver
a contaminação nela Foi fechar os Poços
em
1985 no entanto os esforços da epa que é
uma aquele órgão Americano de
contaminação para limpar o solo e a água
contaminada foram ineficazes então em
1993 foi implementado um plano para
tratar a água e o solo mas os resultados
foram pouco satisfatórios o equipamento
falhou e a contaminação se espalhou
ainda mais então 30 anos de tentativas
frustradas de limpeza mostram a
gravidade do problema necessidade
urgente medidas mais eficazes então
temos que tomar essa tragédia dessa base
militar como uma
Alerta proteger o acesso à água pura e
limpa tem que ser uma
prioridade então é importante que vocês
tenham uma preocupação em filtrar sua
água
de consumo em casa de preferência também
filtrar água
banho e existe sistemas de filtragem que
eu falo em vídeos né tem que dar uma
olhada lá no canal procurar os vídeos
sobre filtragem de água tem vários
sistemas seja osmose reversa troca
iônica filtro de carvão ativado são os
sistemas
melhores e é interessante também captar
água das da chuva se você pudesse Lógico
não faça isso em ambiente de dengue né
mas você não tiver esse problema de
dengue capte água da
chuva que seria uma situação
interessante também para utilizar essa
água para banho né para fazer
lavagens próximo assunto que nós vamos
discutir aqui é um estudo fascinante
eficácia de diferentes tipos de
exercícios para mulheres com obesidade
Então o que eu vou falar agora é uma
coisa até meio óbvia Mas é bom que tem
estudo a respeito né então se você está
buscando entender Qual que é a melhor
forma de exercício para melhorar a
composição corporal e aptidão física
fique ligado do que eu vou falar
agora então um estudo que foi realizado
com mulheres obesas três tipos de
intervenções diferentes para melhorar as
medidas corporais e aptidão física e as
participantes foram divididas em quatro
grupos o grupo que só fez exercício
aeróbico o grupo que fez exercício de
resistência uma combinação do aeróbico
com resistência e o grupo controle que
não fez exercício nenhum então três
grupos de exercício e um grupo que não
fez
nada os principais desfechos avaliados
foram adesão às intervenções de
exercício também o vo2 máximo que é o
tanto que a pessoa consume de oxigênio
no Exercício máximo de de consumo de
oxigênio vo2 Max composição corporal
qualidade de vida qualidade do Sono dor
humor frequência cardíaca e repouso
pressão arterial e força muscular tanto
do membro superior quanto do inferior
então participaram desse estudo 67
mulheres com obesidade idade média de 36
anos
adas principalmente através
de uma organização chamado coalisão
irlandesa de pessoas vivendo com
obesidade esse grupo diversificado
permitiu uma análise sobre como
diferentes tipos de exercício podem
impactar a saúde e bem-estar dessas
mulheres então trata-se de um estudo
randomizado ou seja as mulheres foram
divididas nos grupos de maneira
aleatória éo também controlado durou 12
as participantes realizaram exercício
três vezes por semana com sessões
supervisionadas os grupos de exercício
seguiram intervenções progressivas e com
mesmo tempo total de exercício semanal o
grupo de aeróbico fez de 20 a 50 minutos
de exercício o grupo de resistência que
é força fez de 20 a 50 minutos de
exercício de resistência obviamente e o
grupo combinado os ou ambos os tipos
fazendo 10 a 25 minutos de cada tipo de
exercício então adesão o programa foi
maior no grupo combinado uma média de
85% de presença nas sessões
seguido pelos grupos de resistência que
é o de força e aeróbico ou seja o
pessoal gostou mais de puxar ferro pelo
jeito do que correr na esteira todos os
grupos de exercício mostraram uma
melhora no vo2 Max que é o consumo
máximo oxigênio comparado ao início do
estudo então todos elas todasas mulheres
passaram a consumir mais oxigênio né
então isso uma um sinal de que estavam
melhores assim de em termos de
condicionamento mas apenas o grupo de
resistência Teve um aumento
significativo em relação ao grupo
controle existência exercício de força
que eu tô querendo dizer em termos de
força o grupo de resistência teve
aumento notável na força do supino
aquele exercício supino certo
do
peito com aumento de carga de 11 kg
assim como o grupo combinado que teve
aumento de carga parecido de 10 kg e o
grupo combinado mostrou melhoras
significativas na composição corporal
incluindo redução no índice massa
corporal peso massa gorda percentual de
gordura corporal e circunferência da
cintura a qualidade de vida humor e
qualidade de sono também melhoraram
significativamente no grupo de
combinação em comparação ao controle
destacando os benefícios adicionais da
combinação de exercícios aeros e de
resistência bem apesar desses resultados
promissores é interessante notar que o
principal objetivo do estudo era
determinar a viabilidade das
intervenções de exercício os
pesquisadores não ajustaram para
múltiplas comparações que aumenta o
risco de resultados falsos positivos por
portanto esses achados devem ser
interpretados com cautela e considerados
ainda iniciais
exploratórios Então esse estudo sugere
que a combinação de exercícios aeróbicos
e de resistência pode ser mais eficaz
para melhorar a composição corporal eão
física em mulheres com obesidade do que
os exercícios realizados de forma
isolada então isso pessoal óbvio né se
você associar a com B vai vai ser melhor
do que a e melhor do que B sim mas muita
gente não gosta de fazer exercício de
força então eu recomendo se vocês só
fazem aeróbico que coloquem exercício de
força na rotina de vocês ok e vice-versa
também então se você está buscando uma
forma equilibrada eficiente de se
exercitar considera incorporar ambos os
tipos de exercício na sua rotina beleza
bem eu tinha um terceiro para discutir
aqui mas eu acho que eu vou direto para
as perguntas porque ultimamente tem sido
mais perguntas do que habitual então
vamos lá eu vou dividir minha tela com
vocês boa noite boa noite boa noite
Eliseu só tem vocês três aqui ao vivo
não tem mais
gente então vamos
lá perguntas deixa aumentar o tamanho da
aqui das perguntas na
tela primeira pergunta vitamina C quando
devemos
consumir por quantos dias e por quê
então a vitamina C também conhecida como
acido as fóbico é uma vitamina muito
importante desempenha várias funções no
organismo e as principais delas é asão
antioxidante melhora o sistema imune
saúde imunológica ajuda a bom
funcionamento do sistema de defesa
produção de Colágeno é muito importante
para produzir essa
proteína absorção de Ferro importante
que você consuma ferro com vitamina C
para melhorar a absorção cicatrizar a
ferida e a saúde das artérias e a saúde
do coração a vitamina C É bem
interessante não tem um horário certo
para consumir vitamina C você pode
consumir várias vezes ao longo do dia
se você consumir durante as refeições
você vai ajudar na absorção de Ferro
então é uma
boa e o problema da vitamina C que não
tem depósito no organismo e nem o
organismo produz Então você puder tomar
a vitamina C sereado ao longo do dia é
melhor a quantidade recomendada depende
muito se você não tá sofrendo um
estresse oxidativo você pode estar
ingerindo por volta de 90 100 mg
de vitamina C por dia agora se tiver
passando por um momento de grande
estresse tá uma chamada antiga fadiga
adrenal que hoje chama-se disfunção do
eixo kpa aí você pode consumir 500 mg
várias vezes ao dia ou se você tiver com
uma infecção aguda uma gripe uma virose
pode também consumir várias vezes ao dia
de 500
mg e as fontes de vitamina C são as
frutas
cítricas também tá presente no kiwii no
morango
na manga no abacaxi no melão em vegetais
verdes especialmente brócolis espinafre
couve mas também tá no tomate no
pimentão também tá presente no na
acerola que vocês sabem né E no kamu
camu é a fonte talvez mais rica de
vitamina C na
natureza pessoas que consomem bastante
vitamina C pode ter diarreia então tomar
cuidado com isso se você tiver diarreia
é sinal de que tem que reduzir a
dose existe a possibilidade também se
você consumir doses muito altas e tiver
bebendo pouca água dear cálculo uriná
Apesar que isso é muito difícil de
acontecer próxima pergunta meu cortisol
está 18 minha filha 16 meu marido 5 não
falou que horário do dia foi colhida vou
imaginar que seja de manhã tá o que pode
falar a respeito como melhorar
então nós sabemos que cortisol é um
hormônio muito importante um dos
principais do stresse é produzido pelas
glândulas adrenais ou suprarrenais é
muito importante na resposta ao estresse
mas é muito comum tá alterado também em
pessoas que estão
estressadas também importante no
controle da inflamação no controle do
sistema imune no
metabolismo Então se a gente tá falando
aqui de níveis e de cortisol da manhã o
nível 18 tá dentro da normal Ok 16
também já o valor 5 tá abaixo do valor
que deveria est de manhã tá considerando
que ela tá falando aí de cortisol cérico
do sangue
tá então aparentemente é o marido aí que
tá com problema aí tá com cortisol baixo
de manhã mas é importante medir isso daí
na saliva tá e medir vários horários
diferentes medi uma hora depois de
acordar 16 horas e às 23 horas se
acordar de madrugada medir de madrugada
se não acordar não medir de
madrugada então o principal ponto para
quem tá com cortisol baixo é gerenciar o
estresse com técnica de relaxamento
melhora do Sono
mindfulness suplementar com complexo B
vitamina C magnésio zinco usos
adaptógenos rodiola Rosa Ach Ganda aí
tem vários
aí fazer uma alimentação rica em
proteínas e gorduras saudáveis e cortar
carboidrato exercícios leves A
moderados então são várias medidas tem
muito material no canal sobre isso daí
dá uma pesquisada lá
Ok deixa eu mudar aqui a per
[Música]
pergunta cadê onde é que tá tô com tanta
janela aberta aqui que eu tô até perdido
aqui onde é que tá a janela
do Pera aí me dá só um minuto que eu me
perdi aqui eu não sei onde que tá a
janela Ah tá
aqui há muitos anos adotamos o critério
de ingerir as frutas em geral quase
verdes evitando as maduras havia até
sites ensinando a consumir e preparar
bananas completamente verdes alegando
que ineria amido é infinitamente melhor
do que consumir glicos e açúcar
provavelmente tá falando aqui de amido
resistente tá que é diferente do amido
comum Esse procedimento é útil
considerando que todo amido se
transformará em glicose não depende
amido resistente não vira glicose tá por
isso que tavam recomendando o verde ou
existem outras variáveis e úteis inúteis
nesse procedimento Não entendi com
variável inútil mas tudo bem além da
maior demora dação então a O amido
resistente não é eh totalmente digerido
e nem é processado pelo organismo ele
acaba sendo comida de bactéria tá então
por isso que ele acaba não virando
glicose a prática de consumir frutas
verdes especialmente banana ganhou
popularidade porque ajuda a reduzir sim
o açúcar do
sangue e aumenta o consumo de fibras por
causa do amido resistente é um tipo de
fibra
certo e também a banana verde além de
ter fibra e alimentar as bactérias bo do
intestino e não virar açúcar ela vai
ajudar na saciedade e é outro efeito
benéfico além do controle do
açúcar porém algumas pessoas pessoas têm
problemas de gases com o amido
resistente da banana se for uma pessoa
que tem tendência a cibo né que é o SM
intes bacter brof pode ter enchaço e
gases tem que ficar atento quanto a isso
[Música]
algumas vitaminas e minerais vão estar
menos disponíveis também na banana verde
Isso é uma outra
desvantagem próxima pergunta
esse respondi cara D Alan Minha esposa
tem um nódulo ati descoberto alguns anos
sem variação médico familiar da época
deixou quieto o nódulo não lembro a
explicação uma nova médica
endocrinologista das tradicionais pediu
para tirar amostra do nódulo fazer
biópsia
considerando ser normal mulheres de
idade terem nódulos como encarar isso tá
vamos
lá enil Macedo Boa noite Eliana Boa
noite então o caso é o seguinte tá eh
depende do tamanho desse nódulo e a
classificação dele os nódulos tirades
que é uma classificação do
ultrassom qu e c são geralmente os
nódulos que são biopsiado se for um tis
4 a acima de 1 cm é melhor fazer a
biópsia agora tiat 3 2 1 geralmente não
se faz nenhum tipo de procedimento isso
pode variar às vezes de colega para
colega um colega pode recomendar biópsia
com agulha fina e outro não por isso que
teve essa controvérsia
aí então 90 95% dos nódulos tiroidianos
são benignos s biopsia tirat 4 e 5 e
ainda assim o quatro tem que ter pelo
menos 1 cm para fazer biópsia
tá agora se for nódulo muito grande
acima de 2 cm e for ti R TR em alguns
casos também faz a biópsia
meu fogo está 210 e meu marido 339 Qual
o valor seria
ideal então fibrinogênio ele não é um
exame que deve ser avaliado de forma
isolada dos outros
tá os valores normais do fibrinogen na
maioria dos laboratórios entre 200 e 400
que que significa fibrinogênio ele é uma
proteína que nós temos no sangue e que
tá inativado quando você tem um corte qu
você tem um problema de romper um vaso
fibrinogênio ele é transformado em
fibrina para poder cobrir o machucado e
começar o processo de tamponamento do
sangramento tá então ele faz parte da
cascata da coagulação fibrinogênio muito
alto pode estar relacionado a trombo
não é bom nem ter muito baixo
fibrinogênio nem muito alto né muito
baixo vai
est associado a risco de sangramento e
muito alto vai est associado a risco de
trombo pessoas que estão com infecção ou
com inflamação pode terento do
fibrinogênio sem tá necessariamente
tendo o coágulo inflamação
tá quando paciente com fibrinogênio alto
Geralmente eu passo natoquinase
picnogenol que são anticoagulantes
naturais ômega-3 também
ajuda frutas e verduras que T os
polifenóis também podem
ajudar óbvio que o estilo de vida também
é importante com controle do estress exo
regular som de qualidade não fumar
Ok a aplicação de ácido hialurônico para
restauração da pele não de preenchimento
pode gerar inflamação no decorrer dos
anos o Botox pode gerar problemas a
longo prazo os tratamentos fa estéticos
em geral se feitos por um bom
dermatologista apresentam risco a longo
prazo
bem o ácido hialurônico é amplamente
utilizado em fretamentos estéticos para
restauração da pele ele já é um
componente
natural ele tem a capacidade de reter
água e manter a pele hidratada e
volumosa nos últimos anos ele tem sido
utilizado como antienvelhecimento eu
tenho tomado ácido hialurônico inclusive
para
isso ele estimula também a produção do
colágeno quando ele é aplicado direto na
pele ele pode ter problemas potenciais
tá não é comum mas pode dar uma
inflamação local pode dar reação
alérgica e a formação de granuloma que é
um tipo de reação também que forma um
tecido cicatricial
exagerado já o Botox a toxina botulínica
ele é muito utilizado para reduzir rugas
dinâmicas é uma toxina uma neurotoxina
e por isso como ele paralisa os músculos
da face ele é causa essa redução das
rugas que são as rugas
dinâmicas porém o uso repetido pode
levar formação de
anticorpos isso torna o produto menos
eficaz ao longo do tempo e se a pessoa
errar na aplicação profissional não
tiver um bom treinamento Pode injetar no
lugar errado e dar uma atrofia
muscular e também é muito comum né Vocês
já viram muitos casos eh a pessoa pode
ficar com uma expressão facial muito
ruim né inexpressivo pelo exagero do uso
do
produto tem muitas técnicas de
preenchimento facial que usam produtos
que não tem uma experiência ainda muito
longa de 20 30 anos de uso então é
sempre um risco isso daí tá aí já não é
o caso do
hialurônico e nem o caso do Botox
estamos falando aí de outros produtos
que eu parmente não ten muita
experiência porque não trabalho nessa
área
estética Doutor vi uma entrevista onde
foi dito que as muleres absorvem o DNA
de seus parceiros pelo útero nas
relações sexuais no decorrer da vida tal
fato de
embasamento bem eu acredito que não tá
eu nunca pesquisei ess tema diretamente
mas eu nunca vi isso em lugar
nenhum existe uma situação chamado
microquimerismo fetal que é a presença
de
células do bebê anos após esse bebê
nascer uma mãe que deu a luz e fica com
células do bebê por anos depois da
gravidez isso existe
tá uma situação parecida tá falando Mas
não é
igual existe também um um conceito de
microquimerismo sexual que é isso que
você tá falando mas não tem evidência
científicas robustas que ele ocorre de
verdade tá que comprove que o DNA dos
parceiros sexuais se integrem ao DNA da
mulher de maneira duradora
mas se você achar fonte disso daí depois
eu até vejo
melhor a proteína isolada de soja é bom
para suprir a necessidade da proteína
diária substitui o e como vem da soja
seguro é uma fonte válida sim é uma
opção Popular para veganos que não
querem usar
um produto à base de leite né que é o e
que vem do
soro não é dos meus
preferidos não tem uma digestão tão boa
quanto o a tem menos aminoácidos de
cadeia ramificado BCA do que
o a digestão é mais lenta mas é válido
você pode utilizar assim proteína
isolada de sódio
ela é ligeiramente menos anabólica que
do que o a e também não é tão bom paraa
recuperação em relação a
e Mas é uma opção válida
sim obviamente algumas pessoas vão ter
problema em tolerância com a soja Então
tem que ser observado
isso e também tem a questão dos
fitoestrógenos que têm n soja então eu
não usaria só soja o tempo todo tá Eu
faria alternado com proteína do Arroz
proteína da ervilha do colágeno da
Albumina então eu eu não acho que deve
ser utilizado só proteína isolada de
soja o tempo
todo próxima pergunta
protocolos para retirar de pedras
vesículas são funcionais temos vídeos
sobre o
assunto bem esse protocolo está falando
provavelmente é o protocolo do andras
murit eu já usei algumas vezes na minha
opinião não funciona mas eu acho que é
um bom detox não para retirar visícula
mas por outros motivos tá agora existe
também um remé chamado usol tá o esse
ursodiol
ele pode ser utilizado para eliminar
pequenas pedras de colesterol na
vesícula tá tá falando pedra de
vesícula já a pedra de rim a única pedra
de rim que dissolve mesmo é a pedra de
ácido úrico puro que infelizmente só é
5% dos
casos então geralmente a pessoa que tem
pedra no rim tem que fazer o quê ou ela
vai fazer uma
cirurgia uma endoscopia né uma ureter
flexível ou ela vai fazer uma lit
extracorpórea no caso da pedra vesícula
Se não responder o uso do o
sodol vai ter que fazer uma cirurgia
laparoscópica o sodol também conhecido
como uso deoxicólico ácido uso
deoxicólico
certo pessoas que T pedras pequenas
podem eliminar elas aí já tô falando de
pedra no rim tá e através de hidratação
tomar muita água e utilizar medicamentos
como Alfa bloqueadores que a tanul
losina e doxazosina pode ajudar a
facilitar a passagem dessas
pedras dá uma olhada no canal que tem
vídeo sobre esse assunto lá também tá eh
de Pedra do R Pedra visícula não não
tenho certeza teria que dando uma
olhada exercícios para as vistas são
realmente eficazes para miopia
hipermetropia estigmatismo e
glaucoma eu não estudei esse assunto
profundamente Tá mas existem alguns
exercícios que podem ajudar
sim eu acho que vale fazer os exercícios
antes de tentar utilizar o óculos ou a
lente de contar
ou mesmo a cirurgia lasic
né o os exercícios oculares eles
são interessantes também para fadiga
ocular para melhorar a mobilidade dos
olhos isso pode ajudar também
na prevenção de fatiga de leitura
então rec faça o exercício sim apesar de
eu não terho uma experiência pessoal
grande com isso aqui
não na última Live eu disse que a daa
fila tem efeito menos intenso que o do
homo sim menos intenso para finge
Próstata é o que você está dizendo aqui
mas ao mesmo tempo em outra Live O
senhor falou que tá D fila indicado sim
é indicado mas é menos intenso não tem
nenhum tipo de contradição no que eu
falei tá
então não entendi porque você ficou
confusa vamos lá o tadal fila ele foi
desenvolvido para tratamento de
disfunção eré em homens como vocês sabem
né o seales só que foi descoberto que
também relaxa a saída da bexiga e ajuda
na mixão só que o efeito data da lafila
não é tão intenso quanto dos outros Alfa
bloqueadores que o caso da doxazosina
Transul Usina é isso que eu falei tá se
você tiver ao vivo
Você entendeu o que eu falei agora ou tá
confuso porque não vejo nenhuma
contradição no que eu tô dizendo
né inclusive pode associar os dois pode
US usar tatal lafila junto com a Alfa
bloqueador doxazosina tulina certo que é
o doomo no caso é falando doomo é a
doxazosina Ok Ficou claro o abendazol
não teria efeitos mais sistêmicos do que
o mebendazol
Sim ele é absorvido mais do que o
bendazol e ele é metabolizado no fígado
e tem um espectro mais amplo de ação vai
pegar mais
bicho então o aend para funcionar ele
tem que ser absorvido ele tem que ser
metabolizado no seu metabólito ativo ele
vai circular no sangue nos tecidos e o
membras ele tem uma ação mais localizada
dentro do intestino
porém a ação do medazol é mais Ampla e
pega mais bicho
tá Inclusive eu use usei eu usei bazol
semana
passada Então eu não sei se você entendu
com a bendazol seria ruim porque tem
mais efeito sistêmico não é o caso não
tá
Boa noite também ainha e o Carlos
k Qual que é a dos datina como antiviral
é a mesma dose que você usa para
covid um comprimido A cada 20 kg de
peso tem gente que usa essa dose dobrada
usa dois comprimidos para cada 20 kg de
peso no caso da Lu ela animou muito com
atina começou a usar assim mas eu
comendo
não então se a pessoa tiver 50 kg ela
vai usar três comprimidos porque ela vai
passar de de 40 né então quando você tem
um número quebrado assim você parte
paraa próxima dose então 50 kg de peso
60 kg de peso a mesma coisa em termo de
dose vai tomar três comprimidos Agora se
a pessoa pesar por exemplo 90
kg aí vão ser
quatro
comprimidos 4 a c né se o zinco disputa
absorção com cobre mesmo que helado Por
que que ele é recomendado o uso
concomitante 10% de cobre em relação ao
zinco porque são minerais diferentes a
tua necessidade de cobre é diferente da
sua necessidade de zinco cada mineral
vai ter uma necessidade diferente não é
porque existe competição entre um e
outro que a dose tem que ser a mesma tem
nada a ver uma coisa com a outra
certo você tá
confundindo competição por absorção com
dosagem são coisas diferentes porque não
é porque Zin que cobre compet entre si
que a dose tem que ser igual Espero que
tenha ficado
Claro mas se você não entendeu ainda e
tiver ao vivo a gente pode elaborar mais
boa noite O senhor pode me ajudar nessa
dúvida pode associar áo Alfa Nações de
baixa dosagem com
pramipexol Pode sim sem problema nenhum
não tem interação ruim entre TRS quem
toma não tem paxon tem a taxia cerebelar
não
diagnosticada investigação e que o áo
alfa lipoico eona de baixa dosagem foi
introduzida sem
receita não vejo problema nenhum
associar esses daí
tá o alfal lipoico um antioxidante
potente muito bom pro fígado tem efeito
neuroprotetor é muito utilizado
neuropatias especialmente a neuropatia
periférica do diabético o ldn é muito
bom para modular o sistemo imune para
também doenças
neurodegenerativas tem efeito
neuroprotetor e o
pramipexol é agonista dopamin utilizado
para paron e também síndrome das pernas
inquietas e também para taxia
cerebelar então eles podem andar muito
bem juntos não tem problema nenhum
lógico acompanhamento médico tá não acho
uma boa ideia tomar receita de Alf e ldm
sem acompanhamento
médico essa pósgraduação da aome ela não
existe mais tá ela acabou não sendo
lançada por decisão da empresa que era
parceira que era o paradigma Então esse
esse curso não tá ativo o que tá ativo
agora é o curso de próstata
Ok o COB absor com mais eficiência o
formato do ômega-3 T glicer des
reificado
sim é mais eficiente esse ômega-3 na
forma de triglicerídeos do que o o na
outra forma que é o ésteres
etílicos os triglicerídeos rest
esterificados são uma forma de ômega-3
que passou um processo chamado rester
ificação para voltar a sua forma de
triglicerídeo ou seja tem lá o esqueleto
de de glicerol com três ácidos graxos
ligados a eles esses ácidos graxos são
os ômega3
tá para você identificar um suplemento
de ômega3 triglicerídeos né ou
reificado Olhe o rótulo do
produto produtos de alta qualidade vão
indicar isso no
rótulo e também certificações de
qualidade como é o caso do Eos né que é
o International Fish Oil standards
que é um bom certificado de que esse
produto tem qualidade produto procure Um
fabricante que tenha renome né Aí eu
tenho uma lista que geralmente eu passo
pros pacientes já passei em lives
anteriores por
exemplo existe a marca Life extension
que é muito boa
tem no Brasil você
tem várias marcas também
Tá bom
então é isso
aí é uma boa você usar esse tipo de
ômega-3 sim no momento que estou usando
o celular meu corpo está recebendo
poluição eletromagnética do celular
porém se eu esver descalço na areia da
praia meu corpo está recebendo os
elétrons da terra assim é o grounding Né
o aterramento nesse caso o efeito
aterramento está anulando a poluição
eletromagnética do celular
vai ajudar mas eu não diria que estaria
anulando 100%
tá de modo que eu possa utilizar o
celular à vontade não não afirmaria isso
não não vai acontecer esse efeito como
você tá pensando aí
tá infelizmente a poluição
eletromagnética hoje tá muito extensa e
simplesmente andar na terra ou na grama
ou na água não vai vai ser o suficiente
para poder tirar essa toxicação aí
não mas vai ajudar então realmente
apesar de não ser uma coisa que vai
resolver 100% vai
ajudar eu não utilizaria o celular no
ouvido Procure utilizar o celular no
viva voz e utilizar o mínimo possível
seria esse o principal
efeito aí Não ande com o
celular coloque na mochila ou numa
bolsa ou se você não quiser usar o viv
voz usa fone de ouvido com fio que
também é uma coisa
interessante Não deixe o telefone
celular carregando dentro do seu quarto
à
noite mulher de 68 anos com fibromialgia
e artrite amat com teve tomar nem um dia
de crise tá no nono dia de vesículas
nono dia das vesículas que que é isso Ah
tá das vesículas do do Foster vale a
pena tomar lisina eu acho que vale ainda
sente dores fortes tipo choque tá
tomando decadron e
Novalgina Então nesse caso eu usaria um
antiviral mesmo convencional tá o que eu
mais uso é vala ciclovir mas acho que a
lisina tá bem indicada aí para tomar
junto tá e depois pode usar lisina para
prevenção Além Do Val cicir tem o fan
ciclovir ou ciclovir tá que são os mais
utilizados eu uso mais o vala
ciclovir para dor neuropática uma coisa
que ajuda é a gabapentina ou
pregabalina e alguns mos também
antidepressivos tricíclicos como a
[Música]
amitriptilina deixa eu ver se tem mais
perguntas aqui que eu não vi
antes
Ah parece que só tem 20 aqui é só tem 20
Não tem mais
não tem as perguntas do Eliseu né
você indica alguma marca de pasta dental
à base de óleo de coco eu indico a bone
natural veleda e a life extension são as
três principais que eu indico as que não
t as marcas que não tem fluor tá passa
base de óleo de coco de cabeça agora não
tô lembrando não tá não sei se a bone
natural Tem óleo de
coco mas seria uma opção sim sem dúvida
tá vejo nenhum problema nisso eu não
lembro de nenhuma marca comercial que US
óleo de coco o motivo pelo qual é
raríssimo um bodybuilder chegar 100 anos
de idade é devido ao trabalho intenso
sistema digestório que tem que digerir
tonelada de comida Olha liseu eu não
conheço nenhum trabalho dizendo que
bodybuilder por si só não chega aos 100
anos de idade o que eu conheço é os
bodybuilders profissionais que fazem
competição que tem uma diferença do
bodybuilder amador e o profissional
tá o bodybuilder que compete o que não
compete agora o que compete vai usar
muitas coisas que são muito piores do
que com proteína né vai usar um monte de
anabolizante vai usar um monte de
diurético hormônio de
crescimento Então esse que é o problema
né pess sem top de coisas que fazem mal
pra saúde agora o bodybuilder natural
ele chega aos 100 anos de idade
sim é diferente do bodybuilder que usa
hormônio né
hormonizado cafeína em alimentos ricos
em cálcio iní absorção de Ferro o cálcio
pode competir com ferro sim
tá
cafeína cafeína não chega a competir com
ferro
não boa noite boa noite boa noite boa
noite Quais são os tratamentos atuais
para
osteoporose cálcio né que todo médico
passa
magnésio boro silício enxofre orgânico
na forma de msm que eu emeti o sulfonil
metano vitamina A vitamina D vitamina
K2 proteína
musculação reposição hormonal
e as drogas que inibem a ação dos
osteoclastos né que no caso são
os elementos como ácido hrnic né que são
os bifosfonatos e também tem o aasta Né
que é outra classe de medicamento então
tem muita coisa para
osteoporose Miriam parece que é só para
você ou alguém pode falar se o áudio tá
fraco para outras pessoas
também o a tá dizendo que o áudio está
ótimo então deve ser uma coisa ao local
contigo
miram boa noite
Estela bem estamos com 50 minutos de
Live mais perguntas pessoal porque senão
vou
encerrar Boa noite Cristina Pina
Cristiane Pina
[Música]
perdão Pessoal lembrando que quem pegou
a Live no meio pro final pode
simplesmente ver o vídeo que tá gravado
tá no YouTube ou quem não
pegou nem ao vivo pode assistir a lives
depois vocês sabem disso né
bem pessoal vou encerrar Então tá não
temos mais
perguntas e nós nos falamos então na
semana que vem um beijo para vocês um
abraço para
vocês e até a próxima
semana n